pool heaters being blamed for a carbon
monoxide leak that killed a teenager at
a Michigan hotel over the weekend the
leak sickened 14 other people there
nearly half the victims were children
who lost consciousness after swimming in
this pool they were treated at a
hospital and released
Jericka Duncan is outside the hotel in
the city of Niles it's east of Chicago
tareka good morning good morning you can
see there's a small memorial here
growing in memory of Ryan Douglas Watts
he was among a group of kids here for a
birthday party on Friday but they
decided to take a last-minute swim
before checkout on Saturday oblivious to
a major problem that would later claimed
the life of that 13-year old boy
Saturday morning hotel employees found
six children near the quality end and
Suites indoor pool which is fully
enclosed another passed out in her room
the oldest child was 14 the youngest
just 12 I've never seen anything like
this Niles Fire Department captain Don
wise said the pool heater had a faulty
exhaust vent carbon monoxide levels in
the pool room were over 800 parts per
million even after the doors had been
open that is extremely high they're
supposed to be zero eight children five
rescuers and a hotel housekeeper were
taken to the hospital 13-year old Brian
Douglas Watts was killed
he'd make everybody laugh and he'd come
for anybody who needs stick up for
people
and he was just just a great person I
was shaking him inside on the news and I
didn't think it was real on Sunday
dozens of people gathered at the hotel
parking lot and released balloons two of
Kathy Nikodim grandchildren were
overcome by the gas the parents thought
they were had their children at a safe
place and something like this happens oh
my god carbon monoxide is a colorless
odorless tasteless gas produced by
things like furnaces gas stoves
generators and car engines it can cause
headaches dizziness nausea even death
choice hotels which owns quality and
said in a statement this is an isolated
incident our highest priority is always
the safety and well-being of our guests
people ask you know well how do I know
if I go to a hotel does it have a carbon
monoxide detector or that and I'd say if
you're in doubt spend twenty dollars
take it with you put it on the shelf
state law requires carbon monoxide
detectors and buildings that were
constructed after December of 2009
right now this hotel remains shut down
and will not reopen until it passes
inspections scale
alright Rica such a sad story and seems
like it could have been prevented thank
you so much it's really scary yeah
they're really scary